unacceptable Behavior dude hey dude I
know we're blood but when you're trying
to stack April that ain't got nothing to
do with it jerking a guy off
what is up Chris and Matt hey love you
guys love the show yeah keep it super
short in the same way because I know
that's how my babies love it uh my name
is Nate and I'm a real estate agent here
in Spokane Washington and as an agent
all of my salary and pay comes from
commission which means that if I don't
sell houses I don't get paid and most of
my family understands this and so they
like to support me but recently I found
out my brother listed his home on the
market with another age group and he
didn't even know this agent and also
decided not to tell me and so I had to
find out because one of my clients sent
it to me to go tour it and I had to be
like oh that's my brother's house but I
didn't know that was on the market so
what would you do in this situation what
would you do if your family didn't
support you in your career I also
haven't really confronted them about it
so should I confront him or just let it
go thanks 100
gajillion bajillion percent confront him
and 100 percent
[ __ ]
let him know that that is [ __ ] John
Malkovich
unacceptable Behavior what the [ __ ] is
that first I mean at least let's assume
they're very close but let's assume it's
me and you then that's [ __ ] up
if if that happened between us I would
abs and you were the one that did it I
would be like yo dude what that would be
doing insane if I did that with you but
I would just be like what are you hard
on my sleeve just like what why would
you do that and I would go like this
eating M M's dude don't hate the [ __ ]
game I'm just trying to stack Gaper I
mean then I would absolutely kill you
dude hey dude I know we're blood but
when you're trying to stack yapers that
ain't got nothing to do with it jerking
a guy off
uh no I mean you absolutely I get the
Heartbreak baby but yeah not only
reserved the right to
uh do that you should do that for your
own peace of mind dude that [ __ ] would
make me not even be able to sleep at
night yeah go up to him be like don't
call him don't text him see him and be
like what were you thinking what are you
doing what are you doing you're my
brother why would you do that yes
I mean yes yes uh but okay what about
you [ __ ]
hi yes I know this Blazer's too blue but
why did you try to you know what I mean
yeah start with that start with
something that is going to really hook
them in right unite the two of you in
the same boat we both agreed this place
there's two blue I should get a
different one maybe more muted so anyway
why did you yes but what would fill in
the don't just why did you list a house
and it's not is it because of my blazers
too blue do you know what I mean right
this isn't a color that should be a
Blazer right it should be cancer are you
saying lead him into the wrong answer so
it gives you the right there we go right
right okay well yeah okay yes and then
this Blazer is the the color of
something that would be hanging on a
Christmas tree or something like that
anyway why did you list your house not
with me for for for instance we both
agree that this place there's two blue
now do we also agree that it's shitty
that you did this with the listing yeah
it's 100 yeah because they're both just
they're both equally as obvious let's
list ridiculous things the color of this
Blazer you listed a house and didn't use
me as your real estate agent do you have
any yeah exactly yeah yeah so here here
are the list of very obvious things that
we absolutely agree on right one this
Blazer is way way too blue yes two yeah
listing a house with a realtor who is
not me yes very very [ __ ] three the
Holocaust boy Hitler did is very bad yes
and four ballparks if my character was a
character movie I would be the aide to a
politician so yeah let's yes yeah or
just in real life I look like an aid to
a politician yes 100 maybe you thought
yes to give you the benefit of doubt
maybe you didn't remember right I'm a
real estate agent you looked at me and
thought that is an aid yes to a
democratic policy Oregon yep you know
what I mean a woman and so yeah oh yeah
yeah
um Democrats without question right
right yeah so uh yeah man you got to
bring it up it is weird if you are close
with them it's especially weird but yeah
you just be like yo why did you what do
you not think I'm good at it because you
might say something like off which is
still wrong but he might be like oh [ __ ]
I thought because we were family I
shouldn't have done it and then at least
you could be like oh and he's like I'm
so sorry it might be that but you can
also fix it so so definitely bring it up
just be like oh if it's that he just be
like well of course either way you
should have asked me though it's super
weird thing like why wouldn't you at
least come to me if you thought it was
illegal or something then like just come
to me about it like it would be super
weird like if you were having a a roast
of yourself and [ __ ] Mark Norman was
I'm seeing it you know I'd be like what
the [ __ ] I do like Mark Norman though I
mean yeah he's funny but like you know
I'm your brother
that's a good idea I might do a roast to
myself but Norman host it sounds like a
good idea no no I show up with a blue
blazer all right uh yeah I think that
that's bad dude that dude that's that is
top level
shitty that your brother did that dude
you know
I just get confused
um
it's you
you did it
what the [ __ ] hello hello
hello
[Music]